una sera
tutti sono molto lieto
una città che mi è molto cara dove ho
vissuto per otto anni e che ho lasciato
cinque anni fa ho lasciato la carriera
accademica e ricercatore presso la
facoltà di ingegneria poco per seguire
un altro tipo di accademia attraverso
l'unione raggiungendo lo studio con il
centro studi bhaktivedanta che si occupa
delle scienze tradizionali dell'india
quindi sempre la componente accademica
ma legata alla componente spirituale
la mia scelta è stata dettata non tanto
da motivazioni che non mi consentivano
di essere felice dal punto di vista
professionale umano anzi però molto
felice da quel punto di vista ma proprio
perché sentivo l'esigenza di fare un
percorso interiore nel 2002 ho iniziato
ho sentito dentro di me forte questa
esigenza la troppa razionalità troppo
positivismo mi opprimeva e non mi faceva
sentire felice
finché nel 2007 ho fatto questo questo
salto ricordo che all'epoca la mia
scelta creò qualche così qualche
riflessione e giravano anche delle
notizie abbastanza strane per esempio
una volta ero sull'autobus il 5 che
dalla stazione porta fino a poco è uno
studente venne da me e mi disse o prof
girano delle voci strane su di lei pare
che va in tibet e io ho detto no non
vado semplicemente in toscana vado verso
il centro studi bhaktivedanta e lì mi
occupo di sedicenti tradizionali
dell'india vorrei condividere allora con
voi questa riflessione importante
sull'etica e sulla morale perché è
fondamentale questo tipo di riflessione
oggi in questo mondo che sta correndo
così vertiginosamente ma non seguendo
quei valori essenziali e profondi che
appartengono alla vita di ogni essere la
baghavad gita che è un testo sapienziale
fenomenale importantissimo nella
tradizione in dove dica indica che tutto
ciò che compie un grande uomo e che qua
quando dice grande uomo intendo un uomo
e fonda fondato eticamente allora
un mondo segue le sue forme un po quello
che diceva anche gandhi quando diceva
sii il cambiamento che vorresti vedere
nel mondo indicando proprio la una
responsabilità individuale nel
cambiamento quindi se vogliamo cambiare
volevo portare un cambiamento reale
dobbiamo essere noi a farci portatori di
questo cambiamento
purtroppo questo vale anche in senso
negativo e me perché se molte cose
brutte del secolo scorso che sono
accadute sono accadute sicuramente in
virtù della presenza di personalità
ottenebrate ma che molte persone poi le
hanno anche supportate nella loro
visione distorta e quindi è per questo
che è fondamentale e importante la
responsabilità individuale nel creare un
obiettivo supremo nebbett un obiettivo
trascendente
il bug amata purana che un'altra
scrittura molto importante all'interno
della tradizione della lo yoga del batti
oga individua questo obiettivo e dice
proprio chiaramente in toni forti perché
vado watt a burano utilizza toni forti
proprio per scuotere le coscienze che
qualsiasi occupazione sul piano mondano
materiale ha uno scopo inutile se non
suscita un attrazione per la visione
trascendente quella visione trascendente
che è quella essenziale per raggiungere
interiormente l'ispirazione
quell'ispirazione che porta creatività a
quella creatività vera ed alla
creatività che arriva poi l'innovazione
quindi la crescita ma una crescita
motivata una crescita fondata su valori
etici reali assoluti e quindi per questo
sostenibili e portatori di reale
benessere quindi quesiti che ci possiamo
porre è esiste dentro di noi una
potenzialità che tende ad aiutarci ad
evolvere per il nostro bene cosa
determina la nostra potenzialità ad
agire in un senso evolutivo quali sono i
fattori che sviluppano questa
potenzialità o che invece è invece la
rendono inibita e quali sono i mezzi per
raggiungere questa potenzialità e
proprio derby quindi anche rimanere a
quel livello potenziale innato
ontologico che è presente dentro di noi
purtroppo oggi ahimè le cose sono
disposte in modo non che non aiutano in
questo senso
separare dalla nostra vita a livello
interiore personale ciò che è spirituale
da ciò che invece è materiale e quindi
suddividendo le materie e suddividendo
le aree di studio si è creato quel
quella frammentazione profonda che non
esisteva non sussisteva a livello
storico se andiamo a vedere i grandi
filosofi infatti vedeva aveva una
visione olistica unificata delle arti si
parlava di filosofia si parlava di
spirituali si parlava di matematica ma
sempre con una centralità all'interno
della tradizione vedica dalla tradizione
dello yoga è proprio così
c'è sempre una centralità attorno alla
quale poi ruotano le varie discipline
questo ha portato a frammentazione
questo ha portato ad una scissione nella
quale si è perso l'orizzonte di senso
individuale l'orizzonte di senso
personale verso una visione più
orientata alla superficialità e meno
orientata purtroppo invece ad una
visione di senso profondo ad una ricerca
interiore di quell'aspetto di
ispirazione che ci appartiene
ontologicamente viviamo infatti per
questa è una società fortemente
relativista quindi in cui valgono dei
sistemi di riferimento relativi a non
assoluti conflitto a genna oggi
purtroppo la conflittualità è molto
diffusa non è un dato è un dato
purtroppo ben noto il fatto che la metà
dei matrimoni finiscono in divorzia e me
il 40 per cento dei bambini nasce al di
fuori del del matrimonio conflittualità
molto diffusa a livello lavorativo
quindi relazioni che non sono
armonizzate un ho letto di un sondaggio
che diceva che i
i giovani tra 18 e 35 anni mediamente
hanno 237 amici su facebook mi sembra di
ricordare quando si ha chiesto su quali
di questi amici veramente si può contare
in caso di crisi di crisi personale la
media ha risposto due un quarto ha
risposto uno e un ottavo risposto
nessuno
questo è veramente un qualcosa di
interessante che ci indica qual è il
livello sociale che stiamo vivendo
certamente i mezzi di informazione non
ci aiutano in questo senso
spesso le notizie vengono opportunamente
divulgate proprio per indicare e per
deviare una certa modalità di percezione
è un certo modello di pensiero che non
facilita la individuazione di una
opinione personale di una visione
personale e questo aumenta facilità il
fenomeno dell'influenza mento ovvero
quello di creare dei condizionamenti
delle false identificazioni che ci
allontanano sempre di più dalla ricerca
di chi veramente siamo una volta ho
letto su un tabellone pubblicitario xe
crea il tuo stile però si crea lo stile
allora non è il mio stile quella lo
stile di hicks quindi l'importanza
invece di individuare e una propria
centratura personale capire chi
veramente siamo a orientarci proprio a
quello per individuare poi una nostra
dimensione vera assoluta e profonda
questo perché l'essere umano è
sostanzialmente un paradosso ovvero è
suddiviso tra due proporzione una una
componente armonica sin tropic a
empatica ed una componente invece
entropica la componente antropica quella
che porta al disordine quella che porta
la trasformazione continua quella legata
sostanzialmente alla materia la
componente antropica la possiamo vedere
come leggo se vogliamo la componente sin
tropical a possiamo vedere come il se la
componente più profonda della
personalità umana anche nelle relazioni
di questa mattina che che ho apprezzato
molto ho cercato
scopo di individuare un filo conduttore
è il filo conduttore che ho trovato è
proprio la componente empatica quella
che unisce le relazioni quello che
unisce le persone
quella che consente di creare un
qualcosa di vero di sostenibile ed è di
creativo ed è proprio questa componente
che dovremo cercare di conoscere
profondamente di realizzarla e di
portarla poi a compimento cercando di
utilizzare la componente antropica
quella in continua trasformazione come
strumentale a la nostra realizzazione
profonda quindi non un qualcosa da
negare
non un qualcosa da allontanarci perché
lo yoga non stimola ad una fuga ma anzi
stimola ad un agire nel mondo ma un
agire nel mondo distaccato quindi
collegato ad un piano superiore ad un
piano trascendente un piano vero reale
attuale e sostenibile legato alla
profondità dell'essere questa visione
così conflittuale tra la componente
antropica la componente si in tropic a
presenta all'interno di ogni personalità
è proprio quella che poi porta
sostanzialmente ad una scissione e
quindi le persone non sentendosi
contestualizzate non vedendo non
percependo una dimensione di un
orizzonte di senso quello che accade è
che appunto sentono dentro profondamente
una visione ci sta che le porta poi in
ultima analisi ad una conflittualità
intrapersonale e ad una conflittualità
interpersonale che alla causa poi dei
problemi sociali che noi troviamo ma è
possibile è possibile recuperare questa
dimensione perché l'essere umano ha una
tendenza innata all'ordine e alla
compassione e all'empatia perché alla
sua dimensione vera è la sua dimensione
profonda ed è proprio questa dimensione
profonda che bisogna ricercare
attraverso un atto volitivo per cambiare
dalla biologia delle credenze delle
false identificazioni dei
condizionamenti verso una teologia delle
emozioni perché teologia delle emozioni
perché le emozioni non sono un qualcosa
da da negare
non sono un qualcosa da cui allontanarci
ma se non qualcosa da armonizzare
da conoscere innanzitutto profondamente
io attraverso il centro studi
bhaktivedanta svolgo diversi seminari
nell'ambito del counseling quindi ho
l'opportunità di seguire le persone di
conoscerle e vedo e abbiamo compreso
percepito che la maggior parte delle
persone oggi non riesce veramente a
sentirsi cioè quando si chiede che
emozione stai provando difficilmente la
persona riesce a rispondere qual è il
tuo sentire in questo momento
difficilmente le persone riescono a
contestualizzarsi e quindi è importante
recuperare questa dimensione del sentire
in cui impariamo a conoscerci e
impariamo a trasformare l'emozione a
trasformarla in un senso positivo in un
senso evolutivo in un senso progettuale
alla ricerca proprio di quella
ispirazione interiore ispirazione
personale proprio perché così è
possibile integrarsi impossibile
integrare la personalità e superare
l'origine del conflitto che non
conflitto interiore sostanzialmente di
non conoscenza di se stessi
il metodo è un metodo che richiede
naturalmente una disciplina una
disciplina personale che parte
innanzitutto dalla conoscenza dalla
conoscenza di chi siamo e passa
attraverso l'esperienza quindi
l'esperienza pratica nel mondo di quella
conoscenza perché attraverso
l'esperienza è possibile poi provare
l'emozione quindi provare quello che
viene chiamato un gusto superiore un
gusto che consente di andare oltre i
vincoli del condizionamento i vincoli
dell'identificazione ed i vincoli della
non percezione di sé e radicandosi
quindi con quell emozione sana vera
ontologica è possibile allora acquisire
quella saggezza un quindi una
comprensione profonda di quella
conoscenza ed una saggezza una saggezza
interiore e personale che consente di
fare lo stesso evolutivo dallo step
evolutivo fatto è possibile poi
acquisire nuove conoscenze quindi
entrare in un circuito virtuoso che
porta verso l'evoluzione e allora la
psicologia dello yoga individua
sostanzialmente tre aspetti il primo
aspetto è chiamato sambanda ovvero
la conoscenza della relazione quindi la
conoscenza della relazione ontologica
che sussiste tra noi ed una dimensione
trascendente che e quella che dà un
senso poi alla nostra vita è quella che
dà un senso alle nostre relazioni oggi a
livello familiare a livello amicale a
livello lavorativo
quindi la conoscenza ontologica perché
tutte le tutele la conoscenza della
relazione ontologica perché tutte le
relazioni sono una dimensione di questa
relazione originaria e attraverso i
mezzi per acquisire questa relazione a b
day a sambanda la conoscenza della
relazione a b day ha i mezzi per
acquisire questa conoscenza la
disciplina la disciplina dello yoga
quindi fondare la propria vita su dei
valori etici sui due valori universali e
su di questi basare poi la propria
relazione proprio per arrivare ad una
armonizzazione e che passa
necessariamente attraverso la
meditazione perché il mezzo mediante il
quale è possibile purificare la propria
mente da tutte le false identificazioni
da tutti farsi condizionamenti per
raggiungere cosa l'obiettivo l'obiettivo
e pry oggiana quindi l'obiettivo che la
conoscenza originaria della relazione il
raggiungimento di quell'ispirazione
profonde originario antologica che ci
appartiene
quella che ci dona creatività che ci
dono benessere sostenibile che ci dona
quindi visione e capacità di poter
sostenere la vita nel mondo di stare nel
mondo ma senza essere del mondo quindi
lo stare nel mondo ispirati ma senza
essere condizionati dal mondo
io vi ringrazio e spero di potervi
rivedere presto tutti